mai 1990 gegen mainz merkte
stellungnahme ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem video die damen und
herren ist wurde so unfassbar häufig
wieder in den kommentaren gewünscht und
zwar gang beats tempo in diesem spiel
geht es darum dass ich diese personen da
rechts finden die die arme gerade so in
die luft streckt und maxis trick oder
ich bin nachher max max rating den aber
andere farbe kommt ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht an das erste künstlerische
video auf einer map muss man immer
dreimal gewinnen und dann ist man quasi
der gewinner dieser meckern dann darf
man dem verlierer eine backpfeife geben
und das wird wahrscheinlich immer du
sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht mal wie man richtig
schlägt kevin faber heißer das doch
nicht wahr
ich schlage eigentlich die ganze zeit
aber ich weiß wie so etwas wollen wir
noch mal ein bisschen üben so was sie
nein
guck mal ich hoffe zudem dass für mich
nämlich gar nichts und dann bot sich
alba war es mach deine angst dass der
weg geworden
ich wollte dich wachsenden du nimmst
nicht einfach so unser auto nicht
unterhalten
das ist das entscheidende match meine
damen und herren der jetzt in diesem
match hier den punkt bekommt bekommt von
den verlierern
doch auf weiß noch gar nicht wie das
spiel geht unter einer dauert eine weile
okay gibt eine stange alter nächste
bleibt meine damen und herren und ich
mache es mal eine ansage ich könnte
jetzt drei zu null
ich brauche eine ansage nein nein die
märkte schauen
ich weiß auch frühjahr wenn wir einfach
nur ins wasser reingesprungen jemand
ganz kurz aus schon jetzt finden sie
auch so eine eisfläche und müssen wer
weiß ich dass deutschland das hast du
das wort nachhaltig über die neue das
willkommen an türen
es gibt doch so sachen wie hatte ja ich
habe mich in dem boden liegt ich springe
risiko an hat man muss aber echt das
springen war so ein bisschen vorher
drücken damit er das irgendwie
vernünftig an dem deutschland
[Musik]
dass es trotzdem gemacht hast das gehört
dazu so richtig fahrt auf die leertaste
gehauen es gibt noch irgendwelche
gebiets meisterschaften und dann gucken
wie sich mein video hat und denken sich
nur so die laden wir definitiv nie
erhalten
es war kopflos wie ist es die wacht
waren da als wenn du es gedrückt fest
dann greift er das tier weil die luft
heben und dann ein bisschen schmerzen
weg ja danke danke dicker voll korrekt
dass es mir jetzt noch mal gezeigt hat
sich gar nicht am controller war kommt
vorbei findet ja ich bin doch gibt dir
das hör jetzt welche web hat mir da noch
nicht gehört dass es wahrscheinlich so
eine venezianische ich glaube nicht bei
den bürgern will ja wie machst du da ist
er darauf dass deutschland wie schon ein
ergebnis gehört in portugal kanada
erwarte jetzt nochmal ganz günstig macht
man das mit dem war bei mir die oberen
beiden tasten dann wird durch die ganze
ethnologie jetzt wo er trocken wenn das
was kommen wir gern sprachen
ich geb dir kopflos wieso denn ich schon
wieder spitzen schon an einer wand
freunde ich mach ansage dass jetzt wird
ein 30 alter ihr könnt mir nicht
ihr gewissen firma getrennt alte wir
sehen hier fordern wie max vergeblich
versucht was auch immer zu drucken
1/11 gesehen was das war kreis wollte
ich runter schweiz wesentlich sein warum
geschleudert wow ansage ich mache am
kopf musste kopfnuss warte kopfnuss gibt
ihm doch kopflos yetim doch die
gosbacher gibt sie heißt ja auch nicht
einfach nicht durchgezogen aber dass auf
jeden fall geschlagen der ansage gemacht
und es ist wahr geworden
lass mal keine ahnung diese eine diese
cool ist lasst übrigens unbedingt
freunde 50.000 likes darin machst du
nicht das nochmal spielen sollen wie
reagieren wir deutsche 50.000
gleichzeitig aber ich geb dir die ganze
zeit einfach kopflos du machst einfach
nächstes youtube können daten jetzt sehr
wichtig
ich mache jetzt die beim wrestling
damals ist man so erinnern ich bin
bewusst keine schatten einem tor war
aber drin und seiner wie schmeißt man
werden wir können einfach die türen
einschlagen und so malter mit kopftuch
hatte machte selbst in deutschland
möglich in das spricht aber wieder
drüber weil du jetzt denkt okay der wada
hat ubisoft jedoch der markt hat ein
geschenk für dich gibt kommt kommt auch
die andere seite ich zeig dir lass uns
vom treffen alter alle dass ein geschenk
eingeschlossen ist ist das scheiße das
ist übrigens gerade das finale also der
gewinner von dieser map ist der gewinner
von dieser gespräche ist zu meinem volk
und es geht so nicht
wir lieben dich dok film kopfnuss
kopfnuss kopflos du nichts am boden ich
hab dich hoch und jetzt warum kann ich
nicht er nicht darüber schmeißen mal war
das mal krank dass mein herz was haben
sie zu sagen zum volk
wir müssen am heutigen tag mit ihr
zusammen
[Applaus]
ja das ist so das ding der ich krieg
dich einfach nicht darüber richtig eng
gerade habe ich verstehe immer noch
nicht wie kann ich dich denn aber ich
brenne aber ich bin ich einfach nur die
tasten gedrückt
wir hängen daher weiter einfach haben
wir sind tasten losgelassen
ich brauche noch ein punkt warum startet
eigentlich mal von dieser larry position
ja mein gott was bist du denn jetzt
gucken foto oh mein gott nein nein so
gesehen hast du gesehen wie ich da ich
will nur meine slawischen was mich da
gerettet habe
2014 die 190 g glas versucht mich den
gang bis könig zu schlagen es ist dir
leider nicht gelungen
von daher würde ich sagen ich verzichte
nicht auf die backpfeife sondern gibt
ihr eine frau und damit will ich das
video der stelle jetzt auch wenn meine
damen und herren es euch gefallen hat
wie gesagt 50.000 leichter werden wir
demnächst das ganze nochmal hofladen ist
ein ultra gescheites aber auch lustiges
spiel max kanal ist um in der
beschreibung verlinkt bei max kanal
haben diesmal wieder das hoch bei max
kam vielleicht vor ein paar wochen auch
ein video sonst würde ich jetzt sagen
meine damen und herren das männchen da
ist am 11 12
jobs ist im store nicht nicht da der
charakter mason parodie auf rhodos was
ist ihr vom video das war es jetzt hier
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auch die
glocke klicken dann bekommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]